[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and the
recommendation for Knights for tonight's
speaker came from Danny Hillis who is
co-founder and co-chair of the long now
foundation and the designer of the
10,000 year clock were installing in
West Texas and he has 300 patents
invented was a large part of inventing
massive parallel processing and meta web
which is part of how Google search
actually works and things like the pinch
that you do to make things larger and
smaller on your iPhone that all comes
from Danny he is particularly interested
in how the internet and everything else
having to do with the infrastructure
info structures of civilization going
forward can best to go forward and so
that's why he's strongly recommended the
speaker tonight who is in the thick of
that in various respects
please welcome one vennett
[Applause]
thank you for hosting me tonight it's a
huge honour for me to be here with you
today and to be introduced by Stuart
brand thank you for being you Stuart
my name is Quan and I'm from Earth more
specifically I am from the internet from
1995 to 2018 mostly that's most of the
mimetic
things that are flowing in my brain and
I am a product of your work I'm a
product of the work of the people in
this room and watching this stream
thanks to you to your actions your
thoughts your memes I am Who I am today
my learning and my capabilities have
been shaped but by what you've done the
technologies that you built the systems
that you designed and deployed and the
thought that you left us or you gave us
so for me this is really about getting
to discuss important matters with my
mimetic family with my broader tribe and
without exaggeration with many of my
heroes so thank you Stuart thank you
Kevin Thank You Danny for inviting me to
to this place and thank you so many of
you who are here today who care about
thinking in the long term who care about
these systems who care about where
humanity is headed who don't have your
head in the sand so to speak and who are
here with us to to think a little bit
broader so today I'm not giving just a
seminar but I'm giving a hyper seminar
so that means that we'll be going
through at hyperspeed and through many
things and many times but more
importantly it is to mean that it it is
aimed to be consumed as hypermedia
interlinked and Inter twinkled with
everything else most of the audience for
this discussion are actually actually in
the future people that will watch this
for years to come hopefully if it's any
good
so for those unfamiliar with hyper
seminars let me give you a few pointers
I am NOT going to explain everything
that would take me a century and I would
do a terrible job of it so there are
many better teachers that have existed
and many better explanations that are at
your reach so I invite you to pause and
go look at something else along the way
now your best viewer will be a computer
capable of playing the audio and video
stream
perhaps with captions in your favorite
language or with controls to pause the
stream speed it up or slow it down as
you see fit the 20 teens web or better
will do just fine if you are with me in
the physical room today you probably can
do all of that so don't worry it's okay
because you'll get enough context you
are living here with me in my time so
you're probably familiar with most of
the things you'll see and you'll be able
to rewatch this later on it's a plug for
you to become a member of the long now
so you can watch it in HD you also get
to ask me things in person afterward
which hopefully that will make you know
make amends for you not being able to
pause me in mid-flight and then go look
up something so one last note once
recorded I hope to go back through this
hyper seminar and annotate and link the
hell out of it
maybe with tools like hypothesis or
formats library or other things that you
might make that will take some time to
do and so don't expect it at the same
time as the audio and video for this
drops but perhaps in the future maybe in
a few days a few months a few years
we'll have it certainly you know before
the long now is passed
so with logistics out of the way some
preliminary thoughts I try to see our
multiverse through many different lenses
though I often fail this talk will
survey many things and many times as I
said and it is meant to be a memetic
four-course dinner it aims to raise
questions more than answer anything it
is meant to remind us to have more
perspective and it will sound some dire
alarm bells that I'm quite worried about
but it's also meant to comfort - comfort
comfort I was actually born in Mexico so
that my accent sometimes comes out and
to give us a sense of excitement I want
to I want you to leave this conversation
inspire to work on something
so I will relate some stories unfolding
now and tell you about some new magical
technologies that are that are growing
and I'll try to inspire you to do
something and so that's why we'll start
with some perspective setting now I will
have hope to do a lot and I will
probably fail at some of it but give me
your feedback later on and I will get
better so hopefully in the future I'll
do this again and more people in the
future will benefit so with all this set
up out of the way let's get to it
first course let's get some perspective
I'll take you through a couple of quick
exercises just to get us on the same
page I need you to shake out of your
day-to-day and think much broader the
first one is very easy so let's just
look through a few images just to get us
on the same page
now I'll try this again and this was not
quite at the speed that is a signal
there it would take us a lot longer but
I can't even try to do it you know
proportionately I could try to like do
it log proportionately maybe
so let's write like once for I guess
technically this happened very quickly
my mistake it's taking too long let's
speed up a little bit
took a long long time between the
formation of our galaxy to the formation
of our Sun or so I'm told I haven't
personally verified the fact but so far
the explanations fit with all of our
other frameworks so seems to check out
actually didn't look like that it looked
more like that and quite quickly we got
we think we got the first few organics
and unicellular systems I think this is
probably a few billion years off or
something this transition to go to a
flurry cellular things I'm sorry yeah
eukaryotes took a while like think about
that you know 3.52 to 2.1 billion years
ago a billion years just go to go from
unicellular things to eukaryotes even if
that's off by say 500 billion years
still a very long time
think about that 230 million years ago
dinosaurs 230 million million years ago
think about how much happens in a day
and how much happens in a year and how
fast the world changes it's absurd that
the world was so so similar for so long
we're really young I am totally not
following the right timing but you get
the idea
this all happened like really quickly
right so here's another here's another
way to look at it this is a little bit
of a different exercise and and by the
way I think this is both of these
exercises are best done by picking a
time scale something like a day a week a
month a year maybe and then mapping that
time scale to that day week and so on
proportionately and just try to put
yourself through that experience to the
experience of seeing out you know the
galaxy forming for a long time way
before our Sun happened or the earth
appearing and maybe the first few
life-forms and waiting for a very very
long time before you get to to more
complex forms of life I have to thank
Carl Sagan for this because thanks to
cosmos I got to understand this I
wouldn't have been that clear otherwise
so the second exercise I want to do is
similar but we'll look at it all in
context so a million about a million
years ago fire and stone tools 100,000
years ago cave paintings and more
advanced language 10,000 years ago
writing agriculture farming and so on
1,000 years ago science the printing
press the Enlightenment Newton's laws
and so forth a hundred years ago steam
power railroads lightning involved the
telegraph cars airplanes the computer
the bomb the internet the Xerox Alto the
UNIX the web Google Wikipedia
oh yeah that's where those are ten years
ago the cloud mobile phones
optogenetics 10 years ago with the cloud
mobile phones optogenetics CRISPR
autonomous cars machine learning block
chain systems polar bears dying out
and so on so that's pretty striking even
in a log plot it's fast it really what's
going on right now is really different
from anything that has that we know has
happened before and it's even crazier
when you try to think about it
going in the other direction so indulge
me a little bit and you know in some
wild speculation let's try to go forward
in time as far as we can so within ten
years maybe virtual reality augmented
reality more automation people in Mars
we hope within a hundred years more
drastically by a mechanical mechanic bio
mechanically augmented humans maybe
artificial general intelligence maybe
uploads maybe colonies and Mars and
hopefully nanotechnology within a
thousand years yeah within a thousand
years more interplanetary travel warp
drives AGI Eden or health potential
apocalypse who knows within 10,000 years
dyson sphere's maybe interstellar travel
I don't know within a hundred thousand
years maybe our on-demand probes within
a million years we just completely lose
the ability to just think about this
because what's going on what we're part
of is something so profound so different
from the rest of what we see in space
the the rest of the static stuff we see
in space so profoundly different that we
are changing the universe in ways that
we cannot foresee at all what will what
will do so it is it's really hard to
understand what's coming it's really
hard to know what's coming even around
the corner or something like 25 years
from now 50 years from now and so on and
so this is exciting but also terrifying
because it can go very wrong and the the
last perspective setting oh yeah one one
one thing as the Android Android David
says from from the movie Prometheus big
things have small beginnings and so when
you think of all of the things that you
associate with
and with technology and so on and even
going back to the beginnings of life all
of the all of this it has had quite a
small beginning and so it's hard to
predict not only hard to predict but
it's hard to to estimate the value of
something it's really hard to understand
how things will turn out over time we
can only go for it and try to guide it
along the way and make sure that it
doesn't go in bad directions and make
sure to as much as possible steer the
ship in the right directions but what I
want you to take away from this is
things are being played with right now
that that are presenting some radical
changes to what it means to be human
in ways that you know even though they
cannot be astounding technologies of 100
or 1000 years ago are barely going to
compare to so with that you know there
is danger there is a lot of danger with
us so there are some very very big
challenges so we could blow ourselves up
we of course could be subject to some
random cosmic disaster something you
could go wrong with some viruses whether
it's by our own doing or not we could be
the recipients of some other von Neumann
probes knows we could have you know a
eyes could go bad uploads could go bad
I'm actually more worried about bad
uploads and bad a eyes you know the
devil you know it might be more likely
than then you know some randomly sampled
intelligence going bad we can wear you
know destroying our plan and or
destroying our version or our what we
think our planet is and so on so I'd
like to think about this in terms of the
doomsday index and so this is a little
bit of like a kind of a silly thinking
tool but it's think of it as another one
and another exercise so consider for a
moment how much money it would take to
annihilate all of humanity if you know
some nefarious individual or smaller
organization wanted to do that
let's just think about it for a moment
and think of like what what you would
guess you know these each of these time
skills it would have cost so I would
guess that you know ten thousand years
ago nobody could have done it even if
people tried they couldn't they just
couldn't do it even a thousand years ago
with powerful empires they couldn't have
gone around and actually found all of
all of you all humans and killed
everybody even a hundred years ago with
the you know extremely powerful powers
of those days it was quite difficult to
to get to that point but something
happened in 1945 we unlocked an
extraordinary extraordinarily powerful
thing and then we mass-produced for not
quite mass-produced it but produced a
lot of it and stockpile it and made much
more efficient systems so I claimed that
around you know in 1945 through 1968
could have cost somewhere in the order
of hundreds of billions of dollars to
build a nuclear program and and do that
now
whether or not you can wipe out all of
humanity by nuking everything remains to
be seen
I'd rather not see that so but what's
worrisome is that this is still
decreasing recent questions around
biotechnology and the potential ills
that could come from engineered viruses
and so on make this number go down and
so I've I think curious about this
question for quite quite a while as to
what what exactly is there is a number
today some people as have told me that
they estimate this to be in the tens to
hundreds of millions which is quite low
some people think it's much much larger
than this some people just think you
know even if with all the money in the
world you couldn't convince you know
even ten people to go through the
through with us I don't know I don't
know where reality lies is it over here
is it down here but I would certainly
really like it to be up here
so I really want to make sure that we
don't screw this up we just saw how long
it took to get here we have an
extraordinarily lucky we're part of an
extraordinarily lucky thing we don't
even have a word for this what is it
that we are like we think beyond our
species or our Intel our you know our
civilization or our life tree or our
planets or our galaxy we're part of the
we're an extremely lucky part of the
universe and yes we are the universe
awakening to know ourselves but we
certainly could screw part of it up we
certainly can't blow up the universe
thankfully but we could do something to
set us ourselves back at least another
300 million years like that you know
back to the dinosaur time and and back
here thankfully I don't think we are
even remotely capable of wiping out life
on Earth it's great this is why I sleep
soundly at night but but I do think it
is very possible for ourselves to wipe
out ourselves like humans so we should
you know be careful with these things
because you know this is the budget of
most this is a yearly budget of all
countries or letting the top countries
and they can all afford the doomsday
index so you know every you know some
it's very hard to have a country go
rogue like that but pain maybe maybe
they could or what about you know people
individual humans you know this is the
Forbes 1000 richest people like you know
so the leaderboard of the richest people
and they say a surprisingly large amount
of money compared to you know these
numbers that we were saying before so so
this coupled with like the you know what
is the what is the incidence of
sociopathy right like how many at least
people are gonna go crazy and and try
something bad so of course you know
nothing has happened so far
humans are fine clearly everything is
okay right
well no because as we saw here we didn't
have to worry about this 100 years ago
we have to worry about it now so there's
a lot of people that have you know made
this made this case much better
than I am here or that I will you know
and and you can look up you know this is
a great moment to pause and go look up
ex risks and you know that all the set
of arguments and discussions on what our
specific ex risk that we should be
worried about how to mitigate them what
people are working on this and so on but
what I want to give you here is an idea
that we should be working as hard as we
can to get this number to go up and we
should be thinking of a bunch of ideas
around that so things like hey maybe we
should be controlling some technologies
but hey who controls the controllers can
you trust your governments maybe yes
maybe no maybe not all governments and
certainly governments change so what
happens when those controllers switch to
something else so this is a big part of
so all of the blockchain world in a
sense is a response to government
controls over money to a big degree
beyond just the interest in digital
currencies or cryptocurrencies the ethos
of the entire blockchain movement is a
concern that the powers that be might
not be do acting in the best interests
of other people so are we going to trust
you know the entire all of the
governments in the planet to to all
behave correctly for all time maybe not
and so maybe we need larger scale
systems that can detect problems going
on along the way we could agree to not
build some technologies probably won't
work some people will do it at some
point and I think the keys in making it
ridiculously hard or expensive to wipe
out humanity this is kind of the
cryptographer approach to this you think
of a security problem and you say how
can you make it as ridiculously
expensive as possible hopefully so
expensive that you couldn't you know you
couldn't do it if you try it for all
time but hey if you can at least raise
the bar significantly to decrease the
probability of someone doing this then
hey that's good to do and so yeah this
is very very hard to do but there are
some ways for example replicating and
backing ourselves up as soon as possible
so this is becoming interplanetary right
and so look at this isn't this beautiful
wouldn't you don't we want this like now
so go go SpaceX so this will take a
while but you know it'll take a while to
get this to be fully self-sustaining so
that if something goes wrong on earth at
least Mars will be safe you know I what
fifty years a hundred years certainly
way longer if you know the people that
work on things like SpaceX and all of
the other space companies weren't doing
we're doing what they're doing and when
I point out by the way here when we
thinking about controlling some
technologies that today means get the
governments the governments controlling
all these technologies and deciding with
what happens with them but hey who's
actually trying to get us the space and
back ourselves up it's not a government
it's a corporation what how is a
corporation a lot of people agreeing
upon a singular mission with you know
equity and you know financial markets
involved and short term Wall Street
perspectives you know they're not public
yet but you know that how is the thing
like that actually you know one of the
best hopes today for our long-term
survival why is NASA so underfunded why
are all the space agencies around the
pond is so underfunded this is
ridiculous and it should show that
there's something really wrong going on
with our governments there's something
really wrong with how we're prioritizing
things with how we're thinking about
problems with how we elect who we who we
make part of those conversations and
what we're worried about
when you tap into the Twitter stream
today that the problems that people are
arguing about don't even figure in these
time skills that we're talking about at
all
and so I want you to think about the
problems in your daily life and when you
find yourself worrying about something
that won't matter a year from now or ten
years from now or a hundred years from
now maybe maybe you shouldn't worry
about it so the last thing that I would
you know say we we should do is convince
everyone not to do this but you know
education has failed to contain even the
floor Flat Earth movement and we have a
picture of the earth dammit
right
Thank You Stuart so so we need
drastically better knowledge
distribution systems I'm not even gonna
call it education because education
today just means school and and I really
just mean we need to rethink drastically
how we get humans to know things anyway
I want to leave you with two options and
then switch to the tech stuff because
you know enough enough for that
perspective setting it's all kind of
scary and downer so you can either go
extinct or you get or you can not go
extinct and those really translate to
either you do nothing or you do the
average day to day or you get trapped in
like the you know millio of things that
the all of them you know methods of
control want you to to worry about and
you know I really think that this is bad
and they're responsible or you could
work on solving these problems you could
actually go into figuring out how to you
know preserve the species how to back
everything up just in case how to back
ourselves up how to you know move to the
next realm meaning what happens with
brain machine interfaces what happens
with with uploads make sure AI goes
right please like right now this is a
very very important thing to work on but
you know sometimes making art about this
can have a huge impact sometimes giving
giving other people and interest and an
insight into this stuff will help
drastically make the change and I think
we have to look no further than the
Whole Earth Catalog for this how many
how much of what we do today is inspired
by that movement so just whatever you're
doing I'm sure it's very important and
valuable just make sure that it stacks
up to this because if we don't something
could really go wrong and you know I
considered hey telling you kind of like
my story about how I got to this but you
know it's kind of like less relevant
I'll just
mention that the stuff that I'm working
on is an attempt to go and fix some
other stuff and I'll just and it turns
out to be extremely concrete it turns
out to be very very simple day-to-day
activity can actually have drastic
cosmic impact because again big things
have small beginnings so I'm pretty
interested in on three key problems the
secure communications for q-man humanity
kind of things so this is making sure
the internet goes well or bye goes well
I mean continues to to exist continues
to operate is safe makes does not have
suddenly border springing up which by
the way is a looming threat and that
also means perhaps encryption fully
encrypted communications between people
so things like tor and so on the second
thing that I that I really care about
and I'm working on is secure computation
for Humanity so that means it is very
very important that the computing
systems that we use which by the way us
humans are no longer like our ancestors
in the savannas with the tools with like
the stone tools we have very different
tools and we're plugged into these
things now these things are part of us
so stop seeing yourself as separate from
the devices and the internet and so on I
think it's time that we acknowledge the
the thing that's going on which is we're
integrating into a whole organism as a
whole we have built a nervous system or
over the last 50 years we've plugged
ourselves into it and though it's still
really slow that we still have to type
and read and so on and we have a really
bad you know low bandwidth channel it is
drastically faster bandwidth than before
and it is about to get drastically
better as things like BMI hit so
start considering how you relate to your
fellow humans stop thinking as much
about yourself and think more about the
us because we are becoming in us many
people would argue that we've become and
we've been in us for probably a million
years or so you know in terms of tribes
and and so on but I think this is a
different scale of an us that we're that
we're forming and there's their stuff
around the secure computation stuff that
it's very basic it's very day-to-day
things like making sure that when you
use the service it will survive in a
catastrophe so if you can't connect to
the backbone of the internet you should
be able to to work and so on I'll talk
about this more later but that's kind of
what I mean
and the last one is the secure
flourishing of knowledge and so this is
kind of a catch-all for a lot of stuff
and you know things about better
knowledge distribution systems figure
into this I am obsessed with knowledge
package managers being able to construct
entire mimetic packages that people can
consume and install and then level up
with so things like that I mean book
textbooks right like talk about a great
package manager right like you just
print the thing make your thousand
copies and distribute it all over the
world I think and look back at how what
a kind of tremendous impact that had so
think of better tools like just the
printing press was a tool let's get it
very clear like that was it simple maybe
not that simple but I'm simple to copy
construction that you could easily
spread through through the world and
then drastically level up the bandwidth
of communications with humanity and so
think of things like that today so today
we're inundated by bits so that's not it
we're not we don't want bits faster what
we want is the right bits so maybe when
you look at a page you shouldn't just
look at all bits the same maybe
computers should be able to tell you
what's true or not so when you say see a
statement like hey the earth is flat
maybe the computers are good enough now
to be able to tap into some database of
collective knowledge to sanity check
statements against the the actual
reality that we have we have we're
sitting on hundreds of years of the best
method of finding things out we have the
scientific method we have the data we
have the theories we have the
explanations why are we not cleanly
plugging all of these things into how we
consume information why are we letting
six soon to be eight billion people on
the planet axis tons of information
memes as beneficial and dangerous
we know them to be and just treating all
information equally this is a pretty big
danger so anyway I will I could probably
rant about this for days so I will move
on for a moment perspective setting it's
probably the longest thing it's
definitely the longest thing I'll end
soon even though there's three things to
cover because I think that there is a
massive crisis in perspective I think
that today we live in a world with a
crisis of epistemology we don't know
what to believe most people don't know
about science most people don't know how
they could reason through something and
how to learn about it and so I think
that uh you know if I could convince
everybody in this room to do to do
something I hope it is go figure this
you know perspective Epis Tamala g
problem help people around the planet
learn better and learn the right things
and get to truth to actual
scientifically verifiable theories so
maybe you can't prove something to be
true but we can certainly prove a lot of
things to be not true and all of those
things shouldn't be controlling people
anymore anyway so computing we are in
this crazy face transition from a you
know pre harnessing computing species
used to a post harnessing computing
species and we've had we've gone through
packet switching through building of the
ARPANET to the Internet and the web and
all that kind of stuff and we now are
you know fully integrating with these
systems I'll just go through the entire
history of computing in diagrams really
quickly
this is one of those cases where you can
pause and ponder that is you know
Grant's Anderson's three blue one brown
matte amazing math videos go check them
out
I'll go back and explain these No okay
all of those have laughs to last one
I know you know about Merkel trees so
I'll explain the last ones because these
are the ones that I'm here to explain
the the rest of the stuff you can find
much drastically better explanations
from other people but I wanted you to
get a feel for for what's really going
on most of the advancements in computing
can be boiled down to just how can we
get bits of data to different places
faster or better or more securely and
how can we get functions to be applied
to those bits of data to compute other
data or other functions again faster
better more securely so in the in the
current you know kind of web 3.0
movement that's that's going on that
encompasses both the decentralized web
and the blockchain systems what we're
dealing with is this we're addressing
this problem which is we live in an
extremely complicated environment where
there are tons of different actors it
could be malicious or rational so that's
what the green hat is it's an
accountant's hat where the rational
participant will stick with you if it's
in their best interest but we'll
definitely defect if it's in their best
interest to do so and the the the reason
why the word blockchain has such a big
hype is that it's an example of a crypto
system that takes that very seriously
and has been deployed globally so it's a
it's a system that removes trust from
the equation as much as possible so that
you can have a trustworthy system where
you can reason about the the operations
that you're that you're asking the
system to do so again all a blockchain
really is it's just a ledger of data
that we all agree is right that you're
not gonna suddenly see a ledger of data
that is there's
and because you know data is just
because programs are just data you can
think of shoving programs into this
ledger of data and then running them
effectively that's what bitcoin bitcoin
did it from the very beginning I started
as an idea of just pointing just keeping
in a method of account but perhaps
having as a venue to import actual
programs and having them run is an
extremely useful thing the programs at
the beginning just manipulated those the
balances in accounts but this was a
point in the design space that hadn't it
was very different right so the
throughput of a blockchain today is
abysmal a bad so you can this is partly
why all of this development happened not
in Silicon Valley because most of the
kind of alley people said you're telling
me an accounting system that is worse
than my pocket phone will be you know
will run the economy of the world this
is insane and you know they were right
in in a bunch of perspective like yes
though that system as is won't run the
whole economy but it's a model it's at
OE system that works damn well and shows
how a much drastically better system can
be built that run processes transactions
across the planet so that that's you
know in describing blotching systems and
you know in a nutshell it's really just
about having a way to reason about the
computation agreeing having consensus on
the outcome of events and being able to
upload your own little programs to have
them run it turns out that that is a
surprisingly powerful primitive and what
we are seeing today is is the emergence
of an entire range of applications that
are building sort of a a are taking this
system as the basis of a new legal
structure in in computing so think of
smart contracts and so on where you know
if you think of the vast majority of
legal contracts on the planet have
something to do with moving around
ownership or moving around or or setting
some terms and so on and now you can do
this entirely in a computer and Trust it
in a way that you don't fall into this
you know malicious rational problem you
can just trust the the computers are
doing the right thing
and so this is why this is why there is
a ton of hyper on the blockchain space
and some and so on if you're very
familiar with cryptography and
cryptanalysis been you know known for a
decade and a half yes this is what
happens with computing transitions we
find a really good system that happened
to punch through the you know the
activation energy barrier and then
everyone rallies behind that system and
says oh yeah like you know and this is
all it's all part of the blockchain
world and you can see this with a lot of
the higher you know there's a number of
older companies that are jumping into
the space that are really just building
systems that they talked about decades
ago before maybe not decades but at
least a decade and a half certainly
before Bitcoin and this really just
consensus systems and good crypto
systems but they're all labeled
blockchain now because the the
blockchain movement has garnered such
strength I want to distinguish this from
this decentralized web stuff which is a
similar but subtly different what the
decentralized web stuff is about is
taking the existing current web
computing platform and taking the links
in that computing platform and making
secure links out of those so it's in a
different point in the design space and
it is converging quite quickly to -
blockchain systems and so the the joke
here is that you can think of
decentralized web websites or datasets
and so on as being you know equally
equally sound and equally secure as as
blockchain systems just in a different
nature so there's no consensus involved
and Sarah Lee and so on if you said hey
let's take a decentralized web system
and put some consensus on it then I
would say you have a watching it's a way
to like heal the divide between the two
now a very significant thing that's
going on around all of these systems is
that they present a pretty surprisingly
good chance at building secure robust
systems that you can rely on even in
conditions where your government's your
your are against you corporations to
trying to derail you and so on and so
that sounds kind of crazy but but in but
in reality like what we're dealing with
is just weaving cryptography and weaving
certain systems theories and ideas into
a system capable of processing functions
that's really all it is processing
functions in a way that nobody can
interfere with so if you know that the
function applied then that's fine and
safe I'll mention this stuff and you
know I won't talk very much about ipfs
you can find plenty of other talks about
it we address a number of interesting
interesting problems a thing that we
really care about is offline so most
people on the planet are not plugged
into the computing system the same way
that you and I are they have local
networks they have maybe a good a very
high latency but and very high bandwidth
links a moving a package like a package
hard drive from one place to another but
but they're not constantly connected to
the internet the same way you and I are
so we need to change our computing
platforms to address this kind of stuff
and I'm proud to say that that our work
has been you know helping a bunch of
these conditions we know certain
communities that are using the stuff in
offline regions and we also know that
it's being used actively to fight
certain censorship things so for example
the I profess was used in the in the
recent referendum in Catalonia there was
a a an attempt to you know this was an
example of a Western democracy
immediately deciding to silence you know
a strong push for the before for voice
from from people and they just went
through to the roots of the internet to
the to the ISPs and to the managers of
DNS in in Catalunya and blocked a whole
bunch of websites and it turned out that
our system just works even in that
environment and so I was capable of
moving around information so there are a
whole bunch of other systems like this
that that are being built right now and
are on are getting deployed and need of
course a ton more work to get there but
but the insight here is that we are we
are using cryptography and group
dynamics which we'll talk about in a
moment
very briefly and we're using distributed
systems to yield a computational
platform
that is really native to the internet is
really coming from the electronic
frontier not from you know the
segregated partitioned different
old-world
old-world giant models so so you can
think of think of blotching systems and
decentralized web systems as as a as an
emergence that is building a new
jurisdiction in the world which is the
internet jurisdiction now how it relates
to other governmental jurisdictions and
so on is still yet to see this is a baby
thing that's really dumb for now so I
think of like the worst possible
optimizer you can think of and that's
what it is maybe not not evil one yet
but but but that's that's the the that's
kind of what's happening it's it's a new
way of getting safe and secure computing
and and when these things get completely
encrypted then then you're in a whole
different different ballgame and you
know a lot of people ask me why why I'm
so pro encryption and and you know it's
a really hard question there's a lot of
people on both sides of the encryption
and you know Pro encryption and against
encryption debate that um maybe don't
see the full implications of being on
either side and in the in the anti
encryption side you see a lot of what
has been saying hey look we're the good
guys we're trying to keep people safe
we're trying to make sure that no bad
groups go around and do anything you
know bad to our societies and so on so
we need to be able to look at everything
we need to be able to wiretap everything
and and you know what like they're right
like you wouldn't they are the good guys
and to a great extent they work really
hard to keep everybody safe and they
have very legitimate reasons to be
worried about bad things going on as we
saw before like you know doomsday index
you know it's very easy and cheap for
small groups now to cause serious harm
and damage to the entire species so
naturally a lot of people who have the
mandate to do something about it or
trying to but on the on the flip side on
the other side there's this massive
concern that what happens when those
groups change what happens when a
movement as powerful as the Nazis in the
40s Rises takes control of that machine
and now Institute's the worst Orwellian
nightmare you could possibly imagine
right like that's why that's why we need
encryption systems
and this it's it's a it's hard like this
this stuff is not easy to contend with
because you know damn you do damned if
you don't having fully encrypted systems
will allow some bad people to get away
with that stuff
having no encryption encryption systems
can allow authoritarian regimes that are
completely unprecedented to this day and
so when thinking about these systems you
have to like pause and think through
what you're building because by the way
a lot of people are building a lot of
stuff right now sometimes not really
thinking that much about it which is
should give us pause but you should
really think through what are the
properties that you want the Internet to
have what are the properties that you
want to bake into the network into this
nervous system that we're building and
what do we want the rules to be like
that's what's getting figured out right
now and if you're not part of the
conversation please join it because you
this is the stuff is gonna matter for
the next 20 years a lot and so I think
the you know the crux here for me is you
know what potential negative futures am
I trying to avoid and there is a very
real bad potential future where the
advancements of machine learning the
advancements of surveillance technology
we have the advancements of you know
robotics and so on empower a small group
not to annihilate all of humanity
hopefully that won't happen but but
really to control vast numbers of people
in ways that are extremely difficult to
avert so think of the resistance groups
that we know so much about in the 40s
and the 30s they were able to mount
resistances against bad groups because
they were able to get information to
each other quickly and safely and and
they were able to do things that today
any government would be able to spot so
think of the massive treasure troves of
personal information that the big date
big you know personal data corporations
or the data monopolies things like
Facebook and so on have collected in all
of us and think of where are those bits
of information about us stored and what
did you say what did you say over the
last five years in those systems did you
say all positive good things about every
government or every position did you say
any bad things about bad groups what did
those bad groups suddenly get into power
what if those bad groups get not only
beyond into power but in a position to
be able to find you like that's what
some people are in the world are
actively worried about right now beyond
it being a theory it
is happening and you know there are some
of their tearing regimes where it's
potentially pretty bad and there are
others where it's not so bad yet but it
you know we can see the glimpses of
something that so for example the
current credit system that is being
instituted in China is a good indication
of what happens when you empower a
government to look at everything that
you're doing and then rate your based on
that what happens to dissent what's what
happens to different opinions what
happens with the potential of you know
positive change that is against the line
of the party that is potentially very
bad and if you think that this is so far
away from us think again
groups like you know again in the
Western in in certain Western
democracies this has happened in the
past and it could happen again and we
have seen some indications that even now
where different groups are taking cues
from how China's managing its internet
and trying to apply this to the rest of
the world so there's a a nice
interesting window right now where we
can build really good systems deploy
them everywhere and then have a much
safer much safer computing
infrastructure for everybody and now
what are the rules of such an
infrastructure we don't know yet we need
to figure this out what should be
allowed should should it really be the
case that anybody can send any other
message to anybody encrypted it's a hard
question so far everybody has thought
yes and I am very strongly in that
position but hey you should figure it
out and you should participate in
network knowing what you're
participating in so you know join the
conversation and holla I've taken way
way too much time on this
I'll blaze through this stuff like
really quickly because all of this you
can find online you can pause and ponder
you can pause and look look through and
so on the you know I think the biggest
thing to me that that people don't talk
about enough in terms of Bitcoin and
crypto comics is think of the enormous
amount of computing power dedicated to
the Bitcoin blockchain I'm not gonna
claim how it works I'm just gonna point
out that this thing you know last time I
looked it's consuming about as much
power as Australia so talk about the
insane level of power that just you know
Publishing a paper on the web can have
right so you publish a paper on the web
with like a good incentive structure and
the code you know you have to get there
and then you get this you know
ridiculous thing happening right and so
this is this is powerful human
coordination and and this is just the
you know the tip of the tip of the tip
of the iceberg like the kinds of systems
that we're gonna be able to build with
reasonable and good incentive structures
are incredibly powerful
this is you know what we're thinking
about in terms of data storage is like
hey can we can we take this idea and
repurpose it to build the biggest memory
on the planet can we big Li just
ever-present storage for for everything
for all programs for all data for you
know the very valuable pieces of
knowledge all over the world can we just
back up and replicate everything and can
only encourage just people all over the
planet to do this and so this is the
kind of thing that becomes possible when
you think with crypto economics and so
it you know it's really combination of
economics cryptography distribute
systems game theory and so on and it's
an amazing new field that's gonna deal
with very powerful structures so one
thing that I'll mention is credit
assignments so I've been recently
obsessed with this problem which is how
can we assign credit for the success
among the multitude for decisions so I'm
packing that a little bit when you think
about endeavors think of the blue dot
there think of all of what it causes and
all of the participants that that
influence that endeavor and think
through the potential benefits and
punishments that need to be properly
propagated through the system
I claim and you know this is like the
subject for the entirely new talk I
claim that that solving this system for
humans let alone for machine learning
for humans is one of the greatest
challenges that we have in economics in
this century if we get this right we
could rewire our economies to actually
do good things how many people here
think that our economies are completely
running amok and like causing all sorts
of damage to the world think about the
environment think about like I think
about like what we value today think
about like the short-term returns think
about NASA being underfunded think about
how much we pay attention to things like
a doomsday in there
is the Forbes list actually an accurate
representation of what humanity values
absolutely [ __ ] not I'm sorry but but
this is because we don't have good
credit assignment at all we all over the
place there's all sorts of leakages
where we don't have good wiring of the
system we don't have a nice back prop
system set up in place and then you have
to have people at the end people like
Gillen Moscow you know manage to to
understand the game well enough to amass
a whole bunch of capital and then say
hey look like I've I figured out the
game I succeeded at it some one degree
and now I can do something that's really
valuable let's back up humanity but that
can't be our best way of working that
can't like we have no hope of surviving
if that's the way that we do it and so I
think we really need to step back think
about these problems and building a much
better way to encode our values into our
economy and and if we do that which is
totally possible because again money is
just an invention if we do that then we
will see just very quickly new new
systems optimizing for the right things
and hey guess what it's a good time to
do it because script economics allows
you to test and play with these things
so you know join us in this kind of
stuff I talk a lot more about this thing
in in this podcast and there's other
other many other people that have been
thinking about this problem for a very
long time so you know join the
conversation and I think we solved this
problem in the next few in the next few
years then it could you know radically
change a lot of the world so you know
hyper seminar there's a lot more to say
there and in in one minute I will try to
do the section of knowledge which is
that
but what's going through my head right
now is I this is the thing that I care
about the most
so I'll just really talk about it more
at length in the future I know I'll just
say that the most valuable thing that
humans have ever created and/or will
ever create is our knowledge and you
know you can disagree with me if you
want and and I think that we don't we
have not organized their species for
that yet and we we don't think about
permanence very well and so when you
think about that that a horrible
doomsday scenario of humanity being
wiped out if you think about the threat
models do you do we care if all of
humanity gets wiped out of course we do
but you know what do we want to back up
just in case maybe maybe there's a
situation where we get ourselves knocked
back a thousand years but maybe we can
recover in like a thousand years is know
not bad I mean go go back to think about
that 15 billion year timescale thousand
years is nothing but but it will only
happen if we back up our knowledge well
and thank you long now to we're actually
working on it for being like one of the
only groups on the planet that's working
on it
but but you know we have to work on this
on this more because our permanent
systems need to be so good that even bad
groups can't systematically go and find
those caches and they store them we have
to not only make it insanely expensive
and hard to to to destroy our
information but close to impossible for
example let's build a satellite launch
into space and then have it beam back
all of you know all of the information
by all the information we have to figure
out what all of the information want to
keep is but that's a really good
potentially good system and really hard
to to to go against you know hard to
figure out what it is and so on there's
all all ton of really hard problems and
maybe that's not the best idea but it's
an idea that gets to want to what I'm
describing so we should give digital
information print like qualities today
books will survive vastly longer than
hard drives if you if you some Cataclysm
happened our hard drives would be toast
very quickly and if we didn't get the
data out of them quickly enough then
we're gonna have to resort back to
ebooks and so we'd have a dark age in
there and this is you know Vint Cerf and
a bunch of other people and you know
hundreds of people are working on this
but we're not working on this in a very
well integrated fashion so we need to
and we need to like take take these
kinds of yet like right now like you
know this is this is not the same thing
right and so when you have a sorry I'm
still like a you know normal biological
human you have problems so the when when
digital information which today you know
it's hosted a particular spot and when
you try to view it like your computer
sends messages to that thing and then it
retrieves it real-time and like that's
our basis for information management
like that's super dangerous massively
dangerous so you know this is something
that we're trying to address in the IP
FS project and so on but we're very far
from from from fully fixing it and and
it's gonna take a lot of very
interesting solutions to gather up all
of you know the compendium of all human
knowledge to try and and and save
safeguarded and so you know when we
think you know place to this just I want
to leave you with this idea which is
archiving dimensions think of you know
what should we archive think of the
public record versus private stuff like
private stuff maybe shouldn't be
archived but public stuff should
definitely should we think of the amount
and it's a lot easier to replicate a
petabyte a lot harder to replicate a
yottabyte so let's think of like the
really important stuff to back up and
and back it up in a way that is that
it's safe against you know different
kinds of you know degrees of threat
model like what are we gonna survive
through you know again you know the are
we worried about bit rot are we worried
about you know people going in
destroying data centers are we worried
about civilization collapse and what are
we worried about extinction by the way
one of the silver linings and all this
like you know dire stuff is uh it turns
out that you know we generated all our
knowledge and what 10,000 years since
writing 100,000 years since language
it's not that much so if we go extinct
it's fine
but you know it's probably good to you
know leave records of who we were and so
on for the next groups and you know
think you know thankfully Voyager is out
there already carrying that but you know
I'm particularly interested in this
civilization collapse one because that
one is really dangerous right now and we
could make a very significant effort to
to prevent this we're you know we could
have most of the hard drives on the
planet not work and we could still you
know not lose very many years in our in
our knowledge time scale and and so I
want to fight for that for that future
oh and by the way the type of storage
media matters a lot here so when you
think about the sizes and thread model
and how you want to survive like think
of all of the considerations that went
into where the long now clock is and you
know how how you got to put in in like
the right place to like survive for ten
thousand years like that's a very long
time and a lot is gonna happen in the
planet so storage media really matters
and then how you do it so you know it's
a you know in archiving of knowledge
right now we're doing just the easy
stuff and if we don't do all of the hard
parts of you know this demand of the
space we're we're in a very precarious
position to the point where we could see
another collapse like we saw 3,000 years
ago so 3,000 years ago there was a small
civilization collapse in in the eastern
Mediterranean where a lot of cultures
kind of collapsed very quickly there's a
whole bunch of theories and questions
around why there was a seminar
previously about it and we could see
another case like that in the future
through many of the possible things that
could happen to us and if we didn't back
up our knowledge then we're gonna
setback people a lot longer than we hope
to so in closing I'm sorry that uh that
I've you know taking you through this
crazy ride and roller coaster of ups and
downs and so on you know people asked me
when I when I talk about this stuff how
can you be happy when you think about
all the stuff and in reality I'm
probably one of the most optimistic
people you do one of the more optimistic
people you'll find because I have this
person just you know crazy perspective
and I identify with this you know
fourteen billion year thing going on and
I know that you know overall things are
going pretty well and overall you know
we're doing really well for a bunch of
monkeys and we're like doing really well
for for most life-forms that we know in
the planet and we just have to not screw
it up and we have to push the frontiers
and get to better places and try to you
know make something out of this great
gift that we have and the amazing thing
is that the world is amazingly malleable
so all of this stuff that we've been
talking about all of these technologies
were built by small groups of people
sometimes individuals sometimes just a
single person playing around discovered
something ridiculously powerful that
leveled up and empowered all of humanity
and with our software platform it's just
not much easier you don't even have to
manufacture the thing you just have to
ship a new piece of code and upload
everything you know upgrade everybody
and so I encourage you to become a cyber
Wizard because really what we're doing
here is magical like it's really weaving
you know spells you know we're typing in
our weird languages and shooting spells
out to the rest of the world and causing
crazy systems to emerge and I encourage
you to get involved in labs so this is
you know things like the Lausanne and
Xerox PARC and so on and I and you know
after all I haven't mentioned open
source at all in this talk and I've got
to open source is one of the most
important changes to how we work that's
happened in in a very long time it has
enabled all of us to align yeah open
source or free software you know there's
different ideologies but but a lot of
the same shared perspectives it has
enabled a tremendous amount of
collaboration and cooperation across
international boundaries across
organizational boundaries across
governments it enables humans to just
collaborate on things in in in the
digital you know world in the electronic
frontier in a way that you know just the
world of atoms doesn't do at all you
know not on the same scale and so you
know I think I encourage you to join to
work on these problems I encourage you
to to think deeply about the stuff that
matters most of you
the problems you want to solve and the
encourage you to build and find it or
find or build a community that it's
gonna work with you to do that and you
know I think I think we can totally do
it I think we can totally solve all of
these problems that I described today I
didn't mention a single one that I
didn't think was solvable said maybe
that one probes thing that's kinda scary
but I think everything else is totally
solvable even like the scariest AI
problems or the scariest you know
optimize your problems or you know the
doomsday index and all that kind of
stuff it's all solvable and it's just
gonna take small groups of people it
doesn't even take action of millions you
know it's up to you thank you
[Applause]
ok everybody relax
I'm sorry for staring every we got a
little chance there be a little more
specific about your personal work and
interests would you see something about
file claim which you've been focusing a
lot of time and and inventiveness on and
sort of how file coin fits into this
spectrum you're just described yet
totally so the fact one project is an
attempt to weave the crypto economics
that I described in terms of Bitcoin to
convince people all around the planet to
devote all of the hard drive space that
are not using and wire it all all up
together in a cloud storage platform and
then build all of the you know user
interfaces are on top of a system like
that to enable people to just hire that
storage as they would any normal cloud
computing thing so so think of it as
weaving script economic incentive
structures into a system that convinces
people all over the planet to take
whatever hard drives they can find plug
them together into a system and do
something useful in most of the
computation in Bitcoin is just
completely wasted so in fact on all of
the all of that you know crazy
exponential of power is useful valuable
storage and so we're building we're
trying to build like this you know
permanent memory for for Humanity in a
permanent in the short time or permanent
in that it will only prepare man if we
keep upgrading the systems and upgrading
the media but we think that if we we've
the right incentive structures we can we
can probably do something like that as I
understand it the the Bitcoin mining
which is what uses all that enormous
amounts of power Austrailia worth of
power is improvable fork or things like
that which are a part of the functioning
of the system and you then replace that
with storage which is valuable and
there's somehow an incentive what's the
incentive providing storage yeah so the
the way the falkland protocol works is
that we take the proof of work function
and we found this took a while of
research by the way
we figured out a way to get a good proof
of work that uses a thing we call proof
of replication
it proves that you're backing up a
specific file at a specific moment in
time and if you do that correctly then
it's it's the equivalent of brute
forcing a hash in in Bitcoin it's the
details are much more complicated
encourage you to look at you know hyper
seminar go find the paper read it go
find like higher level descriptions and
there's a number of talks but but the
inside is just take the proof-of-work
function a Bitcoin have it do something
useful and in this case is backing up
storage file corn operating now
functioning system like Bitcoin yeah
it's gonna it's gonna launch in the near
future I profess as a function and
system so you can you can use that
Rockland will be will be hopefully up by
the time most people watch this but not
not yet we hope to be out in the in the
coming months months to a year or
something and then the interplanetary
file system which are you the divisor of
that or the instigator of it or what
yeah weird instigator is the best yeah
so that and that is a working system you
can use it today in fact most of our
websites run on ipfs that system is a
way of addressing all content and you
know giving you that print like
qualities and undressing it through
cryptographic hashes to be able to find
them find the content from anybody who
has a copy so think about right now of
all of the people in this room that have
computers and imagine in bits of
information that you might want to get
that other people in this room might
have or maybe in other people in this
room people in this building or this
block or this city right now the way
that we address information and move it
is by going all the way to the backbone
and back and so ipfs is a system that
just you know leverage the spirit of
here to build a system like that and
then figures out all the content
addressing to slot it into the web so
the idea is that you as a user never see
anything change it just gets better in
anime it's one of the cool things is
that makes offline work so if today
right now the internet connection to the
backbone here in this building broke
then we couldn't interact with each
other even though our computers
are effectively more powerful than you
know the entire Apollo space program we
we could not work with each other the
way we expect and that's just because of
a flaw in how we build the web we build
a web in a way that encouraged just the
content to go into the into the you know
into the cloud and encourage you know
large corporations to run these systems
instead of just enabling linking across
the devices in this room so with IP FS
we can build something imagine like the
Google Docs or a chat system something
real-time live and have it work locally
and you can have this work in an
environment where you know it's
effectively the difference between being
online and offline kind of goes away
offline online being means just suddenly
being able to talk to everybody else but
you should be able to interact and have
you know computation with the people
around you without having to depend on
some random server are in the middle of
nowhere that you don't know anything
about so where does the concept of
content address fit into this and what
is it better than and why is it better
so a Content address is being able to
look at a specific file and derive an
address from the contents of the file
itself so specific way of doing this is
we run use a cryptographic hash
cryptographic hash is just a big
function that you feed a bunch of
information into and pops out a number
and that number is guaranteed to be
unique for that content that number is
so big that you will never get the same
number for two two files even if they
differ by only one bit you'll never get
the same number that's you know
condition of the cryptographic hash and
and this is you know probabilities thing
I will plug Grant Sanderson's video on
how big you know to 2 to the 256 really
is to convince yourself that the
probabilities of you know two numbers
being the same they're so low so we use
a cryptographic function to take any
piece of content or you know really in
our DFS fragments of content and give
those fragments of content addresses
then we can build files out of those
fragments of contents and concatenate
all of them together and you end up with
a single hash that represents
arbitrarily arbitrary large amounts of
data it could be a big file it could be
a directory of files it could be an
entire you know data set it could be an
application and could be the data of an
application and so on and so it it a
when you do that that address that that
identifier does not depend on anyone
except the crypto so you can derive that
address I can derive that address for
the same piece of content anybody else
can derive that address it doesn't rely
on going to a specific server contrast
that to how it works today so today if
you want to post a picture on and say
Facebook or Google or something like
that you grab a picture and you upload
it to the server and you get a URL that
says you know facebook.com/ slash my
picture a dot jpg and then you can go
and give that address to somebody else
but what that means with those people if
they want to see your picture they have
to go to Facebook servers and ask them
for my picture that JPEG now hopefully
Facebook is gonna return the same bits
that you gave Facebook they could return
something completely different or the
connection between that person and
Facebook could be gone so there's all
these problems that emerge out of using
addressing that points to servers and so
if you use addressing that points to
content instead a lot of that stuff goes
away you still have to solve a problem
of how do you find the content how do
you not map a cryptographic address to
you know the participants in the network
that have that content but we have
really good routing protocols in you
know people have invented pretty good
routing protocols and that's a much more
much easier problem to solve then you
know I'm disconnected from from Facebook
and but I'm you know I have I really
want to be able to work with people next
to me and I can't and they said a fond
dream it's this pointers are being
instantiated Chile Oh can use it today
so it's been live since 2015 people that
can go and use IP FS and can build
theirs you know I bet that by now you
probably most people in this room have
at least encountered some piece of
content that is close to three
professors you know not it's not huge
yet but it's getting to the point where
it's I've been seeing it pop it into the
web in a whole bunch of places you can
see the URL you can see URLs and you can
see the hashes and in there and order
some of the pioneering usage the rumor
so I think the very first use case was a
just a lot of people playing around with
it personally like most computing
technology it was just hobbyists playing
with it and using it to move around
their own files now there's two sets
that we think are you know really
important one set is all of the groups
building blockchain applications
to address content in a secure way and
they need something like I profess to do
that they can't address content in HTTP
the same way because it's a different
security model so all of those kinds of
applications use IP fast to point to
images to point to contracts point to
you know that kind of stuff the other
set that we really care about is what we
call large volumes or data start sharing
so think of in a really large archives
of data so this can be from you know in
the small side hundreds of gigabytes or
terabytes and in the large scale and you
know petabytes or potentially exabytes
that's a really massive data set you can
move around data sets like that using
using IP FS and so you can address the
all of the content of a data set and
distribute it and so that's a very
interesting useful cool use case let's
go out of the weeds and back into
doomsday here
your major interest this must have come
online
Tocqueville favi from Denmark says how
expensive is it to make doomsday very
expensive in other words you know what's
the opposite graph of can this be done
cheaply or is it gonna cost a trillion
dollars to make doomsday cost a trillion
dollars so cryptography teaches is that
it's actually quite cheap to build
things that are on the other side really
expensive to break so I would suspect
that we can find a really good ways of
replicating ourselves that aren't there
are in my or not just revoking ourselves
but but preventing them say that are
that are much better so this could be
this could mean as simple as just
changing how we I think it's very keys
dependent so if you think of biowarfare
or something like that the addressing
that looks very different than
addressing nuclear weapons right but in
all of those scenarios there are
probably really cheap ways to address
them it's just more of a human
coordination problem like when you think
about the problems that plague our
governments today they're really not
that expensive or that hard to do it's
just like a huge coordination hurdle
that you can't get people to agree you
can't get people to decide to do
something so we figure out how to do
that right we can probably do a lot of
this other stuff really cheaply
the question has come up from Jay Bryce
Smith her name I can't quite read he
must've written it in the dark
has to do with elections and you know
the worry that people are having that
the elections can be the polling places
can be fiddled of the people can be
fiddled the machines can be fiddled the
code can be fiddle how'd he make a
fiddle free election process and as your
technology gonna help in that so it can
and surprisingly we already was part of
an election in a weird way so the the
Kellyanne you know temp to to do the
referendum not quite an election for a
representative but it was definitely a
vote that was submitted to two people in
that case it happened to our system was
used to distribute information of the
where people could find the polls and
get to them which was trying to be
silenced so that's an example where
things can help
definitely getting certifiable
information is really valuable if a
polling place gathers the data and got
it gathers all the information and posts
you know a certifiable link to it so you
know cryptographic hash of the data and
so on then no other participant along
the way can tamper with those results
now I'm not sure that that's a really
the bottleneck you know today I think
the the real bottleneck is is in human
systems I think humans are going to find
a way to subvert the majority of these
systems and I think in that case I think
potentially corrupt economics and
blockchain systems could actually have a
more interesting angle where you could
do things like just incent a lot of
people that are either trustworthy or
have a really high collateral to pay if
any problem happens is found in the
election and then have a good systematic
way of sampling that and checking that
they've done the right thing and so you
could build just a group of Auditors
that are paid rewarded very highly for
good honest work and if anything is
spotted being wrong have massive massive
punishment you know monetary or
hopefully just monetary but but you can
do systems like that with watching
systems and I don't think any of them
have been are being deployed yet but I
think we could see something like that
up here
the next two or three years now the will
to do something like that it's a whole
other matter I mean how can you how are
we gonna convince a government to do
that when we can't even convince them to
to like let other you know independent
arbitrators come in and check elections
or things like that well you know the
one of the benefits I suppose of
blocking starting as a monetary system
Bitcoin and so on is that the whole idea
of incentive got built in from the start
and so realistic incentive money based
seems part of all you want to do file
coin is part of what I hear from the
etherion people and so you know that you
guys take incentive more seriously than
most yeah I said I think game theory is
probably one of the most important
sciences to understand this these days
because game theory enables coordination
of large groups of actors in ways that
you know we don't really do well yep and
and and I think it's you know thanks to
you know my men and a bunch of other
people that that pioneered this stuff
but I think it hasn't been I don't you
know I think there's a long way of
there's a lot more to discover in those
areas and a lot a lot of ways to use
game theory to to build much better
societies now the careful though because
game theory can also be used for bad
really easily right like you can for
every good use case you can probably
find bad use cases you can somebody so
in this case we had someone like Satoshi
creating a thing to build a payment
system that you know governments can't
kind of rate control and that's pretty
cool but you could equally have an
incentive structure for something quite
nefarious and and so it game theory and
the vast deployment of game theoretic
systems enables groups to you know
without revealing their identity
potentially cause significant harm so
there's something we have to be really
careful about and so we're starting to
see in the deployment of prediction
markets things like auger and so on that
the ethical contract being able to check
the ethical Ness Rolly award are being
able to check how ethical a contract is
is an extremely important piece of the
puzzle
if you don't do that right you can yield
something pretty pretty bad now when you
couple this with fully encryption that's
when things get really scary because
when you can have contracts or
prediction markets emerge that are
opaque and we can't tell what's going on
now that's where you can have some you
know pretty bad and ethical activity
happening so you know I right now we're
in a point where a lot of the primitives
are being built and people are figuring
it out and we can see around the corner
that a lot of potentially really good
valuable things can be built with these
incentive structures and attentive
systems but we can also already see a
bunch of really bad ones and so really
right now is have time to figure out how
we should govern these systems what the
rules of deployment should be what
should we deploy what should we not
deploy how do we know what we're doing
and I think in this environment you know
contrary to most other computing you
know revolutions I think the block chain
systems revolution is drastically much
more concerned with governance and ahead
of the curve than almost any other that
I've ever that I've ever read about so I
have you know it wasn't around for all
of them the but but it's but it's still
far from from from where needs to be
because I think this one needs a lot
more so even though we're ahead of the
curve from everybody else I think we
still need a ton more work to really be
sure that we're gonna deploy really good
safe systems for everybody there could
be some some bad things that get
deployed so help us out yeah governance
keeps coming out saying it's really one
of the things that impresses me about
this whole blockchain world is the
amount of very high-minded focuses put
on the whole idea of governance and
trying various approaches to make sure
that it's ethical all the way down r/w
has a question which others have brought
up with quantum computing looks like
it's coming along and we're talking
about crypto currency and crypto
everything and quantum is supposedly
this great decryption capability when
quantum arrives is that it for
blockchain no I mean there are quantum
safe systems I mean the current systems
that are deployed are I mean this varies
across the systems and what you could do
I believe for example in the Z cache I
think
I think a quantum computer could
probably decrypt the log but in in other
cases but we already know crypto that
that even will be saved through quantum
computers it's just a matter of
efficiency today because we don't have
quantum computers C cache doesn't have
that if they were around the corner then
we would we can upgrade all these
systems to be to be post quantum safe
would want some help
blockchain um I mean you could
definitely do things like so one thing
that we're interested in is so storage
markets is one thing like what happens
when you computational markets so this
is a form of computation that it's not
like it so it's for theorems it's
wanting a log and everybody kind of
agrees and everything we're starting to
see the first few systems that allow
more scalable computation models but but
where this really is gonna head is just
think of a normal operating system task
scheduler of just being able to describe
a job and have it be done once or close
to once and an expectation once and then
get to that degree of efficiency around
the planet and then we'll have you know
markets that run these kinds of
computational systems in various degrees
of security now being able to plug in a
quantum computer to that would be really
cool because then we can run a ton of
computations really really well or so
just being able to enable anybody to use
a quantum computer would be really cool
right now most of the the way that
quantum computers are gonna get
developed is only a few corporations or
governments are gonna get access to them
and that's not great so you know there
might be a democratizing force question
from anonymous do you think having such
a small subset of the human population
fluent in these technologies is
contributing to our potential demise do
you think more people need to learn
computer science you think or what I
mean you know the coding is being taught
hither and yon mostly as a place for an
idea for employment and all the rest of
it we all need to understand blockchain
because if so there's no hope for me
I I think that I think that we're
reaching a time to a lot of people say
that you know you can't really be a
renaissance person anymore and you can't
really learn a lot of things completely
thing that's false I think today thank
you a lot of people in this room are
successful because they learn a lot of
different things so I think we're
reaching a point where the
specialization is gonna matter but I
think your ability to integrate across a
bunch of different specializations is
gonna matter more and so absolutely
everybody should know about computer
science but more importantly everybody
should know about science and just like
how we figure things out and you know
what is like the actual epistemological
foundation that our entire civilization
is built on because when you go out into
the street and you start asking people
like I can get probably guarantee you
the 99.99% of the people you'll talk to
don't really have a good understanding
of how to get from hey we made some
observations to here's a testable theory
- hey this is the body of knowledge that
we know is true and this is a crisis I
think like somehow somewhere along the
way we got comfortable with the fact
that this is going on and we think that
it's okay and it's not it's really
really bad and it's probably gonna cause
tons of problems in the future if we
don't don't fix this and I think what's
really good about social media social me
it is like this you know kind of
love-hate relationship I have with
social media because on the one hand
it's you know every time I look at
almost any kind of social media stuff I
just get really depressed and angry and
and it's because you know anger flows
through social media much better and
like there's a lot bunch of interesting
studies of why and so we just we've
built this amazing nervous system and
we've tapped into just this kind of
broadcast channel with anybody can say
anything to anybody else and the things
that propagate the most are just these
extremely angry often fake things and so
social media just gets us all to be
really angry and about things that don't
even exist which is you know crazy but
on the flip side what the silver lining
in all this is that right now by giving
everybody a voice and creating this
broadcast channel we're now suddenly
getting to see all of these different
perspectives and natures all these
different perspectives and levels of
understanding around the planet and and
we're getting to see that them all in
one go like this isn't we don't get to
pretty
and that they're not there anymore we
don't get to pretend that they don't
exist or the that you know everything is
you know peachy and and everyone you
know agrees on on the very basic facts
of life we can you're getting to see
right now that of the sake you know
six-two gonna be a people a billion
people on the planet like most of them
disagree about the basic foundations of
reality and most of them disagree about
what's true or not in in very basic
testable things and this is something
that we really need to correct as
humanity and we should you know be
working on this and and working on you
know gentle compassionate ways of doing
so of helping people level up helping
people learn I claim that humans are so
good at learning and our brains are so
powerful we could be learning at you
know kind of PhD levels across multiple
fields and I think that this is true
about almost everybody on the planet
I've rarely found people I've rarely
found people that you know if you if you
don't like you gonna step back and try
it you know you have to tell my really
hard to like decomposed pieces of
knowledge into into something that you
know they'll be happy to accept a lot of
the times is just a version to it and
and you know people are super capable
and so I think it's it's a a we need to
approach this from a perspective of try
and level up everybody on the world
think think like Carl Sagan did like why
did he do cosmos he wanted to get
everybody on the planet to understand
what's going on and like we need you
know thousand more more pieces of work
like that so last question Kevin Kelley
raises you use the word we
who's we for you who's we for me it so I
think for me and I probably used to knit
a few different contexts there we for me
is I think probably are the the case
where it makes the most sense to say it
it's perhaps our tree of life because we
don't yet have contact with other trees
of life and I think at that point would
be really great to see or other
intelligences I would you know let's
distinguish intelligence from life and
so that's probably the thing that I'm
most you know excited or worried about
like hey you know the the earth project
is going really well or oh no like
there's danger on the earth project and
so that's mostly what I probably
identify with but you know I think we're
part of something much bigger than that
even our entire life
you know the vastness of space is really
enormous like I'd encourage you to spend
like a week of your life just pondering
the enormity of space and just pondering
just how many galaxies we know about let
alone might exist and what if you know
the you know I think for five different
versions of the multiverse that exist
now that we you know conceive of we are
part of something so enormous Liebig the
and we are so young you know how it's
it's a how dare we think that we haven't
figured out how dare we think that you
know things like the second law of
thermodynamics have it all spelled out
we barely we barely just got out of you
know like you barely just took our
blinders off and I suddenly understand
what more the universe's and so there's
so much more for us to learn so much
more for us to discover and so much
potential like a I you know it's it's an
amazing amazing to be alive it's amazing
to be part of humanity this juncture
it's if I can if we can do something to
help it survive and help it point in the
right direction that'd be awesome if we
can help explore more that'd be great
but I think most most importantly let's
just not screw it up sir here thank you
thank you
[Music]